so in the last video we started working
on the analysis of an RLC circuit that
had a forcing function and the math for
doing that gets really hard and so what
we decided to do was see what happens if
we limit ourselves to using just
sinusoidal inputs inputs that look like
sines and cosines so I want to continue
the introduction to the sinusoidal
analysis technique and just give you a
preview of where we're headed with that
so when we make this limitation to
sinusoidal inputs there's a big prize at
the end and the prize is that the
differential equations turn into algebra
that's the reason we're doing this it
just basically becomes really simple
just like the resistor circuits that we
used to do they were all algebra there
was no calculus we're going to turn
these kinds of differential equation
circuits into algebra so if we're able
to convert this circuit into an algebra
problem instead of a differential
equation that means we can use
kirchoff's voltage law we can use
Kirchhoff's current law we can use node
voltage the node voltage method or the
mesh current method just like we did for
resistors and these this whole set of
techniques then automatically gets
applied to circuits that have inductors
and capacitors in them just like we
learned how to do with resistors it's a
major simplification so let me draw the
circuit over here again real quick the
one we were looking at earlier we have V
we have an inductor here we have a
resistor and a capacitor
so for VN we're going to limit ourselves
to just sinusoidal something like a
cosine Omega T plus Fifi is a phase
angle and we're going to represent this
in a way that looks like this this is
going to get transformed or changed into
something looks like this it's going to
be called a at the angle of V this is an
angle symbol and this is referred to as
a phasor this has a name this this way
of writing this way of writing down
sinusoids if I have a sinusoidal ooks
like this is a function of time I can
write it as a phasor where I say V
equals a at an angle of fee and
understood is that there's this Omega T
term is cosine Omega T term nearby so
the other thing we're going to learn
about is how to transform a circuit so
we can use this sinusoidal steady-state
analysis so the inductor it gets
transformed from L instead we write down
s L where s is that same natural
frequency whenever we have a resistor we
write down just a are just like we
usually do and whenever we have a
capacitor we write 1 over s C and again
this s is the same thing as we had
before the the natural frequency and in
a future video will justify why we can
make this transformation and what this
means the big payoff here is I'm going
to write a KVL equation around this loop
and watch what happens watch how easy
this is it's amazing so let me real
quick I'm going to just indicate sines
of these voltages there's the inductor
voltage there's a resistor voltage
there's the capacitor voltage and here's
the voltage on V n like that we'll give
it that polarity it's not obvious yet
but I get to use these quantities SL + 1
over SC just like they were a resistance
value in Ohm's law and watch how this
happens
I'm just going to write KVL around this
loop and what I get is that V in is
equal to the voltage across the inductor
plus the resistor plus the capacitor and
I can write it like this I can write SL
times I plus R times I plus 1 over SC
times I and if I can write that again
I'll write that one more time
it's I times SL plus R plus 1 over SC
all right that was a straightforward
application of Kirchhoff's law now if we
look at this expression here look at
this right here this is the
characteristic equation we just wrote
down the characteristic equation correct
R is stick
we just wrote down the characteristic
equation of this circuit using these
transformed components now what I want
to do next we're going to actually get a
new concept I can write an equation like
this I can say V n divided by I I'm just
going to take I over to this side of the
equation here equals SL plus R plus 1
over SC this is an interesting idea here
is a ratio right here this is a ratio of
voltage to current now if this was just
a plane resistor the over I for a plain
old resistor is what is R that's an
expression of Ohm's law so now I have
another expression over here for
something that's written in terms of my
component values and this natural this
frequency s that's going on in here and
this is going to lead us to a general
idea of resistance that is called
impedance so that's what this is right
here this is this ratio of voltage to
current and the symbol you usually use
for impedance is a Z so this is where
we're headed over the next several
videos to justify what we're doing here
we need to go through some steps and so
what we're going to do in the next
couple of videos is we're going to do
some review
so here are the things we're going to
review we're going to review some
trigonometry so so cosine and sine and
those functions and what they mean
especially when they're functions of
time we're also going to review Oilers
identity Euler's identity is important
because it's the thing that allows us to
relate e to the J X and we get a some
sort of relationship to sine of X and
cosine of X and if you remember when we
were solving differential equations this
was always the form that was the easiest
solution to come up with e to the
something and if we're limiting
ourselves to sines and cosines for
inputs we need to have a way to make a
really easy way to solve equations so
Euler's identity is the is the trigger
that allows us to do that now when we
use Euler's identity we're going to get
this little complex number that keeps
coming up so we're going to review
complex numbers
that's the three review topics and then
we're going to move on and we're going
to do after that we'll define something
that these phasers then we'll look at
the transformation
so that's that's SL and R and 1 over SC
phasers is the idea where we change a
cosine into something at a phase angle
and then finally what we get to do is we
get to solve so that's the sequence of
events that's what's coming up over the
next couple of videos it's a really
powerful technique for handling some
very complicated circuits and getting
them to do what we want